the gyro can experience they killed kids
all the time like when people leave a
Python in a room with their baby those
horror stories I've read a bunch of
those
the Python drops down and kills a baby
I've heard it even like Python comes
from a neighboring apartment drops down
through the ceiling and killed a kid
bro-bro imagine you're getting wrapped
up by a Python and you see the face
coming over your head and you realize
what's going on let's clamp it on your
head and it detach is his jaw and it's
spreading around you're like oh my god
you can't move your arms you think your
shoulders broken you're getting squeezed
as it's doing this and it's got its
mouth on your [ __ ] head it's slowly
starting to take you into its body I get
scared of animals that like aren't even
threatening like I get scared of like
squirrels and whatnot if they look at me
the wrong way they're right next to you
in a tree and they put some of those
things pretend like because I live right
next to a really awesome Park and I run
through there almost every day and some
of these squirrels they're like people
squirrels I guess they must get fed a
lot or something from humans walking by
and they will pretend like they're going
to like they will just get right up in
your face
aggressive squirrel I got scared at my
chair in my hallway the other day I
thought this is so stupid but I was
coming out of the bathroom was the end
of the night and my chair that I have
this one extra chair that sort of like
moves around the living anyway it ended
up at across the end of the hallway and
it was just sort of hanging out and for
some reason it sort of looked like there
was like a crazy person
like there was a person yes super scared
like like the type of scared because I
thought it was a person leaning back
smiling and immediately my brain
registered that as if there's someone
leaning back smiling in your living room
you're completely [ __ ] you've got real
issues right like my and so my heart
literally like felt like it was like I'm
like [ __ ] here is the next seven minutes
did you just watch the Joker no I
thought some crazy person was in your
house now I did not just watch the Joker
but I did watch though you're scared
squirrel
as well you were saying yeah I mean they
can be freaky they can thicken they can
act a fool you know you know what it is
I think I think a lot of people feed
squirrels yeah there's a park in North
Hollywood
I remember going there once and watching
his old dude on his back and he would
just lay on his back and pick up peanuts
and hold them and the squirrels would
come over and put their hands on his
hand and then take the peanut and run
away with it they did it all the time
and they wouldn't even go that far
they'd go a few feet from him and and
just start eating their peanut and then
other squirrels would come by and they
apparently had some sort of a they've
been doing it so often people know they
could just as long as you're not making
much movement you look safe and hold it
out there they'll come get it from you
but did you see the video of the [ __ ]
monkey riding a motorcycle yes that
pulls up and tries to steal a baby
unbelievable if you haven't seen this
this is the most 20/20 video you will
ever see it is 20/20 in caps lately this
is a [ __ ] mad the world's gone here's
a monkey on a motorcycle that go zipping
up the street bales off the motorcycle
and tries to steal a baby my favorite
part of it is I I watched it like 20
times in a row and I loved how the guy
taking the video from his top story
apartment like is laughing it starts and
you don't see the monkey and then he
sees the monkey on the motorcycle and he
starts laughing and he's laughing more
as it gets closer and he even laughs one
more beat when the monkey grabs the kid
cuz he's like ha ha you know like he's
like watch here's the monkey on the
motorcycle bails and grabs the kid
throws the kid to the ground it's a
little baby and starts dragon only tries
to steal him and as he wants to eat the
baby yeah it's like a horror movie at
that part dude and that guy runs out
chasing after the monkey monkeys will
kill you and eat you that's a fact if
you're a baby in particular monkey kills
12 day old baby after snatching it from
his breastfeeding mother and family home
but row where is that at
where'd that take place popped up I was
looking face oh my god what does it say
there
in India Agra yeah oh my god
the latest warning sign that primates
are being forced into cities a search
for food amid environmental destruction
this is November of 2018 no no no I know
no I'm saying imagine what they're like
now I was gonna say because did you see
that thing about what's going on in
Thailand where there was nobody in the
street so there was just like hordes of
monkeys rather through the street that
are starving that are used to tourists
feeding them so they're just hordes of
monkeys running through like where the
[ __ ] is everybody where's all the food
bro it's crazy watch this it's so weird
it's so weird and then on top of that
rats in New York City rats in New York
City there's no restaurants open anymore
right so the restaurants are not
dropping off the normal amount of
garbage and these rats are accustomed to
it their whole ecosystem is dependent
upon it look at this starving monkey
gangs battle in Thailand as coronavirus
keeps Teresa way look at that look at
that [ __ ] picture oh [ __ ] the streets
are filled with monkeys dude if you're a
little kid and you go wandering into
that I guarantee you they will kill you
and eat you guarantee you you're a
four-year-old kid you go stumble into
that you're dead they'll tear you apart
you know they don't have rules such a
strange animal like they're smart and
they're sneaky like look at this video
oh no social distancing whistle ever
this is rats those are like rats yeah
they're so dangerous like did they're
not they don't give a [ __ ] about you and
they look mean some of them have mean
faces because they've been used to other
monkeys being mean to them and
everything trying to eat them and kill
them
look at that [ __ ] they tear this one
apart oh my god see this is the thing
about rats now rats are cannibalizing
each other for sure they're gonna kill
babies and eat babies these these little
crazy monkeys own people are feeding
them good better keep feeding them
better feed them poison to many of them
see how many monkeys that was yeah
[Applause]